let's talk about Newsweek or Joe Biden
White House brags about social security
check increase caused by inflation
this is one of the most epic mistakes
ever made by a political organization a
political Administration
they said
uh where's where's the Tweet seniors are
getting the biggest increase in their
Social Security checks in 10 years
through President Biden's leadership
what happened was Twitter had a
community fact check which said actually
it was a 1972 law passed by Nixon and
the reason the increase is happening is
because inflation is insanely High
so the White House deleted the Tweet
they accidentally celebrated that under
that inflation was caused by Joe Biden
you get that they said through Biden's
leadership
they're seeing this increase
talk about a major
cell phone
yeah that and I don't like okay if my
dollar deflates so now it's worth 50
cents and I give you two dollars
uh yeah okay you could say that the
value of the dollar goes down the money
is inflated so the value deflates we'll
call it that uh so if I give you two of
those dollars that are each worth half I
can't say that I increased the amount of
money I'm giving you yeah you can that's
what they do it's a lie I know this is
what America does the United States will
borrow let's hear a simple version they
borrow 100 bucks from Japan and that
hundred bucks is worth say 100 apples
like what's the real value
100 apples then they print another
hundred dollars cutting the value of the
dollar in half now that same hundred
dollars Japan has can only buy 50 apples
so when they when they say I got to pay
you back they pay them back half it's
it's amazing how this stuff works yeah
yeah the value of the dollar has been
going down dramatically and and the
crazy thing is it's not as bad as it is
other places in the world like in Europe
and the developing world holy cow are
they dealing with larger inflation
numbers here we're still seeing
artificial way artificial ways that it's
being kind of tamed but there's a reason
why I have this Banker t-shirt there's a
reason their practices that they're
doing is absolutely immoral and evil and
at the end of the day just screws people
over because if you have a if you have
money say you're trying to save up for a
rainy day you put it underneath your
couch or your mattress whatever it may
be that value of that money is being
slowly liquidated Away by governments
unknown tax which is inflation and we
still haven't seen the larger
ramifications from it this is just the
beginning of the larger Financial
ramification patients that we're we're
seeing not just from covid but also from
those two thousand dollar checks that
everyone got it's it's it's crazy that
we have pretty much free money free
money yeah it's free it just comes out
of nowhere it's not free AOC what did
she advocate for debt spend deficit
spending yeah don't you know modern
monetary policy just print the money
spend it and devalue the savings of
everyone else yeah who cares yeah yeah
your wages become worthless and modern
currency is based on trust that's the
thing too and with the trust in the
government's going down dramatically
um and every other government as is with
the recession going on too and China
becoming more powerful I I seriously
think the US dollar just can't keep
doing this taking every bashing because
it won't come out on top and at the end
of the day the world Global Currency
will switch on to something else that's
why China's devalue of their currency
they're probably playing for long game
and one day they're gonna bounce up and
everyone will switch I mean credits due
where's due Russia put their currency
back up partially on the goal sounded
right do you see a price shoot up but
nowadays the currency actually has no
real value and it's just uh it's just a
paper straw that's about to break
basically yeah China also is dealing
with a lot of very heavy Financial
ramifications especially in their uh
real estate market and there's just
there's just so much irresponsible
centralized banking going on that it's
absolutely Reckless to have any faith in
the system if you have faith in the
system you might as well believe in clap
in Santa Claus and and uh the Easter
Bunny you have more faith and and those
made up ideas than you should in the
banking system when you truly find out
what's really happening behind the
scenes and now we're on an infinite
Reserve System meaning the banks can
just print out debt endlessly so expect
inflation to get substantially worse and
never stop getting worse what knowing
that and having no or losing faith in
that system the faith-based system the
Fiat system actually means Faith uh what
would you advise I'm not a financial
advisor I'm buying Dogecoin anyone I
didn't say that I said Dogecoin Dogecoin
and uh no I'm kidding I did buy Dogecoin
but I I would not get anyone advice on
what to do because honestly I have no
idea I would say be care I'm not a
financial advisor but what happened
during the Great Depression was a lot of
people were taking out loans on um
margin margin meaning they didn't have
the money to cover the loan if the value
dropped of the commodity that they were
and then the banks called the loans back
in and they had no money because the
value dropped and then they would have
to sell off all their assets at a loss
to pay back the Margin Call uh so I
avoid I avoid that right now I don't
know what the market could drop by at
times you know one thousand it'd become
worth a thousand I mean the problem is
being compounded because they've been
prolonging uh uh a correction they've
been making sure that there's going to
be no downturns in the economy and they
artificially do that they have been
inflating this bubble more and more and
more and because of that when it does
finally correct itself there's going to
be so much pain there's going to be so
much suffering and these policies were
just being deliberately done and we're
screaming hey this is stupid this is
stupid this is stupid this is going to
lead to more pain more Havoc more
suffering for everyone on and no one's
listening and we're just continuing on
with these same policies to now the
point where the correction is going to
happen it's going to be massive and it's
going to hurt everybody I saw a story
about this guy he found a a tin full of
cash in like his attic or whatever I was
like Grandpa hit up there and it was
something like 50 Grand or whatever and
they were like wow so amazing we found
50 Grand I'm like that sure does suck
yeah because it was worth 500 Grand when
your grandpa put up there if only bought
gold and put it up there or or stock and
some empty lot in the city that's now
developers all around yeah we're like
yup the cash is worthless you'd think
that like a president's gonna come in
and be like all right everybody things
are going to be very very very painful
here's why now it gets painful that
everyone would blame that person that
President like you were saying earlier
who wants to be a politician in this
climate like and then what would they be
looked at as the worst president of all
time because they were the ones that
finally allowed the facetious system for
a lot of reasons Biden already is but
sure any but he hasn't he hasn't done
the financial break he's trying to like
push it push it push it kick it on to
the next next guy by printing more money
and like slowing but it's just like CR
building pressure so that when it does
explode it's going to be a bigger
explosion yeah maybe you could
transition to a better system without
having a giant explosion you're still
gonna have to pay the bills
right
I don't think you have to pay the
Federal Reserve back all that interest I
mean it's a private company what what
right does a private company have to
demand of the US government anything you
know I'm gonna be very cynical here and
say they're doing this on purpose
because think about it all these people
especially the body Administration by
thinking four-year terms nothing else
they don't think about 10 years down
live 20 years and the budget
Administration knows they've screwed up
with Biden completely they know they're
going to lose the next election election
I think they have some self-awareness I
honestly think they're just trying to
print as much money as they can line the
pocket of their friends like we're doing
right now until the next election cycle
in say two years and then the bag is
passed over to the new right-wing
president and then certainly
um effing collapses like you said yeah
it's gonna happen yeah it's their plan
they want to basically sink you know the
ship I have advice for people
buy chickens
chickens will live in pods they will eat
bugs and they will give you eggs I was
talking with our chicken tender Kim the
other day and apparently what you can do
is take cows in one Paddock they live
there they poop there then when they're
they've saturated the area you move them
to the next Paddock and then you move
the chickens into where the cows were
they start sifting through the cow poop
refreshing the grass they regenerate the
land we don't know the chickens destroy
the grass but they'll they'll actually
they till that whole it's crazy so we so
we we cut up we sectioned off this area
for the chickens and it was Tall Grass
the chickens went in and annihilated it
and get it ready for for a crops they'll
get rid of all the weeds which is the
grass and then they'll you have right
crop land but you mentioned something
that I want to add on specifically here
even the same thing about chickens just
to change the topic on their favorite
topic here uh I think what you mentioned
is right and it's not just you know a
politician that's going to come and save
us because if we look at what's been
happening here it's not a democratic
problem it's not a republican problem
it's a duopoly problem as of course we
got to remember Biden is spending money
like crazy he's deliberately destroying
the energy sector he's he's passing the
inflation reduction act which doesn't
reduce any inflation at all and then of
course we had the other guy beforehand
that also spent a crap ton of money on
the military-industrial complex and
started handing out two thousand dollar
checks to everyone like it just came out
of nowhere so so whether it's Donald
Trump Biden or even Obama or even Bush
or Clinton before him they all made this
problem worse and what makes you think
that another Republican coming into
power is going to help this it's not
but you think that I think Miles you're
making the point that they're gonna plan
to get someone of the political party
they don't agree with in power before
they tank the economy and who's there I
think I think bigger than the economy as
soon as uh say the next Trump gets
elected basically now the Republicans
will win now yeah they'll win they'll
win the next election basically but
they'll cause the global crisis they'll
time it because they've got all the
numbers they'll go over calculations I
think they know what's gonna happen if
our time it's such a point that the big
recession happens when Republicans come
back into power and they'll go oh look
what Republicans have done they've come
into power it was bad underneath our
terms but that was because of trump and
then they'll say look we're in power now
it's worse than ever not even I think
Trump's going to be playing playing the
game here if it's a populist if it's
someone who's going to come and be like
hey I could finally represent the people
of America I think China Wall Street and
all these other larger financial
institutions and the Federal Reserve
will come to them be like you will okay
we'll we'll destroy this whole game
right now you better play along or we're
going to tank the economy deliberately
and blame it all on you what do you want
there buddy and I think the next
president even if they're going to be a
populist even if they're going to be
representing the will of the people
that's the perfect opportunity for them
to finally drop all the bags oh yeah you
know I used to be an investment banking
analyst for a few months as well and
I've got still friends of our field and
I met Martin shkreli a few weeks ago you
know for a few meetups lovely guy but
they are sounding alarm Bells right now
they are basically saying hey I'm gonna
put some extra money aside and liquidate
and put some crypto or I'm gonna buy
some extra food or I might buy some
Farmland you know and learn a little bit
about farming or raise my kids to learn
how to uh so close back together and
these are Bankers owning you know two
hundred thousand dollars three hundred
thousand dollars a year at the minimum
things will only get worse you will own
nothing and you'll be happy yeah check
out this so I'll give you one of my
shirts next time you're around them you
could wear this if my career doesn't pop
off and I have to go back to that
lifestyle I'll wear that to the
interview thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there